I grew up on Harry Potter man I love  everything about it Mike Evans is  totally a Gryffindor Haley's Gryffindor  Ron Hermione what you think about Tom  Brady what house would he be in  Slytherin  what about my guy Jalen Rams Slytherin  Slytherin they're talented you know but  they're a little more like you know  Savage than yeah all the other houses  I'd probably be Slytherin as well too  man what you think about Aaron Rodgers  huffle Puffs Hufflepuff Hufflepuff Rob  Gronkowski well gronk's going to  Gryffindor with me he's Gryffindor  Kelsey Gryffindor Jameis Winston  Ravenclaw Raven Arabic  Curry cousins Hufflepuff Hufflepuff for  sure Russell Wilson the Ravenclaw Justin  Jefferson just lived in a Gryffindor I  go Slytherin I got one more Marshawn  Lattimore I knew that was coming when  you said I got one more you start  smirking slithering man yeah